LAURA LING: You build these
really cool, unique structures
of these tree houses
and these campers.
And they're smaller dwellings.
JAY NELSON: Yeah.
LAURA LING: Is there something
about the simplicity of it all?
JAY NELSON: Well, originally
that's why I started doing it.
I mean, I was right
out of college.
I wasn't really making
any money at that time.
And I wanted to be an artist.
And I wanted to figure out how
to live a lifestyle that was
just as minimal as possible.
I had a Honda Civic CRX that
a friend of mine, his mom
had totalled it.
And she gave it to me.
I, for a while, just
drove it around.
And then eventually, I just
thought, well, maybe I'll
build a box over it.
And then I was like, actually,
maybe I'll build a camper,
like a little place
to sleep up top.
What really did
excite me about it
was that it was
kind of like I was
driving this artwork around.
And I mean, it was really
exciting the way people reacted
to it.
And I guess I saw it
as like, wow, this
is a real kind of direction
I can go with my work.
LAURA LING: Tell me about the
first tree house you built.
JAY NELSON: I built one
when I was 10 years old.
And then my friends and I
all through high school,
that's what we did.
We just built forts.
We weren't really interested
in girls or-- [LAUGHS] we just
weren't.
We were interested in
building forts and surfing.
We never really grew out of it.
And they just became
more and more elaborate.
LAURA LING: It's amazing.
These trees are
beautiful, first of all.
JAY NELSON: You
can come this way.
Watch your head.
LAURA LING: Wow,
we're so high up.
JAY NELSON: Yeah, it was pretty
crazy working on this thing.
I fell off the roof once.
Luckily, I had a harness on.
So it was OK, but--
LAURA LING: Super, super
cool and beautiful.
So tell me about the
vision for this tree house.
JAY NELSON: For me
with tree houses,
I don't really like to
come up with a total plan.
Like, we had an idea
what it would look like.
But I really like to be able
to come up here and just
start building it and kind
of see where things go.
I think it's really hard
without actually being up
in the tree to really understand
the type of tree house
you want to make, and what
you want people to see,
and the landscape
you want to showcase.
LAURA LING: What was the biggest
challenge in building this?
JAY NELSON: This was
a really hard project.
Building the roof was
really, really hard for me.
I mean, every single piece
has a different angle.
It was really one piece at a
time, figuring out the angle,
cutting it.
No, wrong.
Go back.
Do another one.
Cut it.
And it took forever.
LAURA LING: Tell me about
the materials that you use.
JAY NELSON: I've always
used found materials.
I mean, everything has a story
and comes from somewhere.
And then also not just
that I know the story,
but they're also visually,
they have a story.
Well, this is a pretty
nice piece right here.
It was a piece of the floor
from this firehouse, which
I thought was cool.
And it's a really
beautiful piece of wood.
It has all sorts of wear.
And it's really nice.
So I saw that.
And I thought, oh, that would be
perfect to create this loft up
here.
LAURA LING: One of the most
striking things about your work
in these structures
is that you're
taking this worn,
discarded material,
and then you're
giving it new life.
JAY NELSON: Like to me, going to
the lumberyard and buying wood,
it just feels like dead trees.
But old wood that you find and
it's like this exciting hunt,
that has life.
Right away, it has life.
Well, the cool thing is, like,
I'll find a piece of wood.
And it will just look like junk.
It will have nails
on it and paint.
And then I'll take it home.
And I'll just start
working on it.
In a couple hours, it's like
the most beautiful piece of wood
you've ever seen.
LAURA LING: What do
you hope people get out
of your work and your art?
JAY NELSON: I would like
people to feel inspired.
But I hope that it helps
people, kind of changes
their perspective a
little bit on things,
and kind of opens their
life up a little bit
to new possibilities.
LAURA LING: Be sure to
check out this next episode.
KELLEY LEWIS: All
the things that I
have used, such as the windows
and doors and the stove,
have all been
recycled materials.